[Música]
Donald Trump es el primer ex presidente
en la historia de Estados Unidos que
enfrenta una acusación penal el fiscal
especial Jack Smith le imputó 37 cargos
en el caso relacionado con documentos
clasificados a Trump lo acusan de violar
la ley de espionaje por llevarse
documentos de seguridad nacional que no
debía tener después de que abandonó la
Casa Blanca en enero de 2021 y también
lo señalan de conspirar para obstruir la
justicia y hacer declaraciones falsas a
los investigadores que en más de una
ocasión le solicitaron que devolviera
las cajas que tenía en su residencia
Privada de Mara lago Florida en la
audiencia ante la Corte Federal de Miami
Trump Se declaró No culpable y en una
intervención que hizo en Georgia y otra
en Nueva Jersey culpó al presidente Joe
biden de ser el artífice de todo para
deshacerse de él recordemos que Trump es
precandidato presidencial por el partido
republicano y biden aspira a la
reelección en ese contexto Trump habla
de una cacería de brujas escuchemos yo
soy el que sigue la ley Yo soy el único
es Joe biden y su corrupto departamento
de injusticia ellos son los que creen
que está por encima de la ley nunca
antes ha habido dos estándares de
justicia en el país
nombraré a un fiscal real para que
persiga al presidente más corrupto en la
historia de los Estados Unidos de
América Joe biden y a toda la familia
criminal biden
el caso se trata de una persecución
política contra Trump o es una
investigación judicial con todas las
bases legales para judicializar al
expresidente Y cómo impacta esto en su
carrera presidencial hoy en el debate de
France 24 discutiremos sobre los
documentos clasificados por los que
acusan a Donald Trump para ello nos
acompañan desde Miami Jaime flores
portavoz en español del partido
republicano y Antonio Molina estratega
demócrata y analista político
bienvenidos aquí al debate de France 24
y a ustedes nuestra audiencia Los invito
a que dejen sus comentarios y preguntas
en las redes sociales con el hashtag el
debate f-24 estamos en Twitter Facebook
e Instagram como arroba franz24-raya al
piso es mi Twitter es arroba María
claguire Los invito también a que
escuchen nuestro programa en las
plataformas de Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y TuneIn
quiero comenzar dándole la bienvenida a
Jaime flores Gracias por acompañarnos
Usted cree que estas palabras que
pronunció Donald Trump son ciertas o no
y que tanta verdad o no hay en Llamar al
departamento de Justicia como de
injusticia y de acusar al FBI y al
presidente Joe biden de corruptos
bueno nosotros todos María Clara
conocemos el estilo del expresidente
Trump lo que nosotros como partido
republicano pues vemos con mucha
preocupaciones que efectivamente estamos
notando dos estándares de justicia en
los Estados Unidos porque también
aparecieron documentos clasificados en
poder del presidente Joe biden uno de
ellos en la universidad de Pensilvania y
otros en su residencia en el estado de
lawer y no hemos visto por parte de la
Justicia del departamento de Justicia
del FBI ni de las investigaciones en los
diferentes más ni siquiera hay un
proceso judicial abierto por la
responsabilidad que cabe al presidente
por haber mantenido estos documentos
mientras que lo que vemos por el lado de
Trump es de una velocidad de supersónica
en meses ya tienen Prácticamente todo el
proceso montado y todo la cuestión
armada y esto coincide además justamente
y vemos esto también con mucha
preocupación con el mismo día en que se
revelan documentos que implican a la
familia vayan en recibir dineros
Aparentemente son sobornos procedentes
de ciudadanos de otros países de que sí
efectivamente nosotros creemos que hay
dos estándares de justicia en estos
procesos Antonio Molina bienvenido aquí
a France veinticuatro usted coincide con
Jaime en que hay dos estándares de
justicia y qué opinas usted de los
pronunciamientos de Donald Trump de
catalogar de corruptos tanto al FBI como
a
Bueno ya sabemos de que eso siempre eso
de herramienta de tratar de tirar
mentiras en cada palabra que queda
sabemos que hasta el momento verdad
Claro está yo no trabajo en el FBI o en
el departamento de Justicia sabemos que
las investigaciones están procediendo
verdad a en base a a cualquier otra
persona que haya cometido actos como los
que se le han culpado y y han sido allá
en directed en la corte Federal acá a
Donald Trump a que desde el 2016 desde
que salió de oficina perdón a ha
mantenido documentos el cual el
departamento de Justicia ha tratado de
recuperar porque al final del día esos
documentos no le pertenecen a él sino
que le pertenecen al gobierno de los
Estados Unidos y lo cual a él nunca
quiso verdad a acceder a las órdenes del
gobierno para presentar los documentos
que sabía que tenía detenido y que
estaba tratando de ocultar a y mantener
y en varios casos dio información
confidencial secreta y hasta Tab Secret
a personas que no tenían el derecho de
recibirlas Sin embargo qué opina usted
puntualmente de los dos estándares de
Justicia que dice Jaime Y qué
comparación hace usted entre el caso por
documentos clasificados de Donald Trump
y los documentos hallados en la
residencia de biden
bueno como decía verdad no sé a qué
punto está la investigación contra el
ahora corriente presidente biden en base
a documentos que él tenía creo que parte
del problema acá también fue verdad que
el presidente Trump a propósito tratar
de ocultar que tenía los documentos
mintió en varias veces de que ya no
tenía documentos cuando en realidad
Todavía tenía más de 102 documentos en
su posesión Y eso creo que en causa es
lo que ha traído el problema verdad
tengamos en cuenta que acá a personas
por ejemplo en el ejército que que
comparten información confidencial
secreta o top Secret pueden presentarse
los mismos cargos de lo que estamos
hablando hoy
le devuelvo la pregunta a Jaime porque
Antonio nos hablaba que Donald Trump
nunca quiso acceder a las peticiones que
hizo archivo nacional y que hicieron el
FBI de que entregara los documentos que
tenían su residencia de María lago y en
el indiment o en la acusación que le
imputan a Donald Trump se lee pedazos de
la conversación con su abogado en la que
le dice si no es posible no entregar los
documentos o en caso tal destruirlos que
responder ante eso Jaime
primero cuando se produce el
allanamiento de Lago mire usted la
diferencia en mara lago se produce un
allanamiento mientras que en la casa del
presidente vendió la Uber van sus
propios abogados a apoderarse de los
documentos para entregarlos había
negociaciones cuando se produce ese
allanamiento entre la los abogados del
presidente Trump y las autoridades del
archivo Nacional de manera que no es
Exacto eso ahora tengamos bien no lo
mencionas o de la acusación
pero me parece muy interesante que el
señor Molina ya está dando por juzgado
el caso ya está diciendo como si fueran
hechos pues asuntos que están siendo
justamente motivo a la investigación y
además motivo del juicio esto es una
acusación de 37 cargos que en realidad
los abogados expertos lo resumen apenas
en cinco que podrían ser también
complicados lo es cierto pero la verdad
es que lo que se busca también con esto
María Clara es crear un sistema de
propaganda que perjudique las
intenciones del expresidente Trump de
aspirar de nuevo a la nominación
republicana algo que dicho sea de paso
pues ha sido un verdadero fracaso porque
lo que ha logrado es aumentar la
popularidad del presidente y hasta las
recaudaciones de fondos de su campaña de
manera que pues ya el presidente ha
salido airoso de varios procesos ya
hemos demostrado que lo que se montó con
una supuesta confabulación con los rusos
en las elecciones del 2016 fue montado
en una serie de mentiras armadas por la
ex candidata hillary Clinton y el
partido demócrata eso ha quedado
claramente demostrado acabo demostrado
también la inocencia del presidente
Trump los dos procesos de independen de
perdón que se lo hicieron en el congreso
mientras estaba en la casa blanca de
manera que pues todo esto es parte de un
aparato de de de de de de propaganda y
además de una persecución implacable e
inmisericorde de la que ha sido objeto
el señor Donald Trump a lo largo de los
últimos siete años usted coincide
entonces con las palabras de Donald
Trump quién habla de cacería de brujas
en su contra
Sin lugar a dudas si el presidente Trump
no estuviera en las condiciones en que
está en la campaña para su reelección
presidencial después de haber dejado el
cargo Hace cuatro años pues no estarían
persiguiéndolo como lo están haciendo a
nosotros nos avergüenza como democracia
que estemos Al mismo nivel de un Nicolás
madura en Venezuela o de un Daniel
Ortega en Nicaragua que cuando tienen
que deshacerse de sus adversarios
políticos simplemente les aplican la
justicia y terminan llevándolos a la
cárcel Esto no es la democracia en los
Estados Unidos nunca lo ha sido y no
deberá hacerlo Antonio son comparables
las presidencias de Joe biden con la de
Nicolás maduro o Daniel Ortega de
Nicaragua absolutamente que no acá en
los Estados Unidos del departamento de
Justicia actúa independiente de de la
presidencia aparte de eso el Señor Jaime
y claro tiene el derecho y tiene la
razón en un punto de que sí Estos son
solo en timers quiere decir que no ha
sido
encontrado culpable a eso todavía se
tiene que ver por el sistema judicial de
igual manera que también tiene varios
otros cargos presentes en otras
jurisdicciones incluyendo en el estado
de Georgia por tratar de de cambiar
el resultado de una elección Federal
donde el pueblo de el estado de Georgia
declaró que él era El perdedor Pero esto
como te decía antes es algo que él
siempre continúa a hacer es la manera
que él opera verdad La idea es decir
falcidades hasta un punto que la gente
lo crean y van a continuar haciéndolo
ahora en base a cuáles van a ser los
resultados en las primarias del partido
republicano Creo que todavía están por
darse a ver como decía todavía hay
varios casos pendientes en diferentes
partes y en parte sea culpable o no
verdad la realidad es a si sigue
teniendo o tomando acciones como ha
tomado él que presentan la posibilidad
de llegar a un punto donde pueden ser a
ser encontra culpable de quebrar varias
normas y reglas no solo a Federal pero
estatales y locales en varias
subdirecciones a ninguna persona es
inmune de la ley Ah y cuando las leyes
se quiebran por eso está el sistema
legal para poder adjudicar esos clases
de problemas usted dice que el
departamento de justicia de Estados
Unidos es independiente sin embargo es
preciso aclarar que este departamento
hace parte de la rama ejecutiva a la
cual por supuesto también pertenece la
presidencia del país Le quiero preguntar
a usted Antonio que piensa de las
diferencias que plantea Jaime entre el
allanamiento que hubo en maralao en la
residencia de Donald Trump y la búsqueda
que hicieron los propios abogados de
biden en su casa
Bueno hay dos cosas que aclarar ahí
primero que todo Ah el sistema judicial
trató de la maneras
sin tener que obtener un un Warren
verdad de obtener los documentos la
razón porque tuvieron que llegar al
punto de obtener un un orden para poder
adentrar a la propiedad de Trump Es que
él seguía mintiendo y no estaba
presentando los documentos como tal si
él a todo proceso trató de esconder y
ocultar materiales que él sabía que
tenía en su posición
segundamente a como decía Las
investigaciones que están pasando con el
momento con con el presidente Trump o
con el vicepresidente
todavía no se sabe a qué etapa está en
esa investigación o si va a salir algo
en base a esas investigaciones de último
creo que es idóneo verdad de que él diga
que esto es un cuando él está llamado
llamando en todas sus conversaciones y y
eventos públicos que si él es reelegido
va a perseguir a a personas demócratas a
por acciones que él
reclama que supuestamente existen
Y qué opina usted Jaime de esta opción
que plantea Trump y que incluso
escuchábamos al inicio de crear un
fiscal especializado solo para perseguir
judicialmente a Joe biden
A ver primero la cámara de
representantes que tiene ahora mayoría
republicana después de las elecciones
del pasado mes de noviembre está
investigando lo que tiene que ver con
las acciones de la familia biden en la
presencia de Hunter haciendo negocios
con gente en Ucrania con gente en Rusia
y con gente en China de Por qué miembros
de la familia biden han recibido dineros
de personajes de influyentes en estos
tres países es sin saber exactamente ni
dónde está el dinero ni de dónde vino el
dinero ni Cuál es el propósito de esos
pagos que se le han hecho a la familia
no solamente la cámara de representantes
está haciendo esto debería hacerlo
también el departamento de Justicia pero
como bien lo dices María Clara el
departamento de Justicia depende del
ejecutivo que pues es controlado por el
presidente Joe biden de manera que por
ahora no lo han hecho bien dice el Señor
Molina que pues hay investigaciones
sobre lo de Joe biden y sobre lo de Mike
pence Pero la verdad es que la velocidad
con que se viene adelantando lo de Trump
es mucho más rápida hasta el momento no
tenemos ningún indicio ninguna
a nadie nadie ha sido llamado como
testigo no se han solicitado pruebas que
tengan que ver con esto también hubo
mentiras por parte de la administración
y de biden la misma secretaria de prensa
de la Casa Blanca Karim Joan Pierre dijo
públicamente desde el estrado de prensa
en la casa blanca que ya la búsqueda de
documentos en la casa del presidente
ande la había concluido Y eso era falso
todavía después aparecieron algunos
documentos de manera que también Ellos
están aprovechando su presencia en la
casa blanca y en el gobierno para
mentirle a la opinión pública y eso a
nosotros nos parece gravísimo sobre eso
no se ha adelantado ninguna
investigación a nadie se le ha dicho que
ha estado mintiendo sobre el tema a
nadie se le ha dicho que ha estado
obstruyendo la justicia pero cuando el
acusado es un republicano y
particularmente es el presidente Trump
entonces la justicia sí funciona y todos
los aparatos están debidamente
sincronizados sin embargo hay una
precisión también por hacer y que es
necesaria y de la cual Le quiero
preguntar primero hablar y explicarle a
nuestra audiencia la clasificación de
los documentos en Estados Unidos que
tiene tres categorías confidencial
secreto y top Secret esto dependiendo
del nivel del daño que se estime que la
revelación o la publicación del
documento pueda hacerle a la seguridad
nacional siendo confidencial un daño
siendo secreto un daño grave y siendo
top Secret un daño excepcionalmente
grave y en la casa de Donald Trump en
Florida en mara lago concretamente
Donald Trump entregó en enero de 2022 15
cajas de las cuales las autoridades
comprobaron que había 197 documentos
clasificados es decir con alguna de
estas tres categorías incluyendo varios
de ellos top Secret la máxima categoría
de seguridad y en agosto de 2022 cuando
allanaron Mara lago las autoridades
encontraron otros 102 documentos
clasificados que Trump no había
entregado a diferencia del caso de Trump
en el caso de Joe biden las autoridades
no han dicho públicamente un número
exacto de documentos clasificados e
incluso hay versiones de que no las han
encontrado que responder ante esto Jaime
Exactamente eso es lo que nosotros
reclamamos María Clara mientras que por
un lado están funcionando las cosas con
Pues con precisión de relojería por el
otro lado aparecen aficionados no tienen
evidentemente ningún interés en que
nadie salga culpado en lo que tiene que
ver con los documentos de biden ahora y
otra cosa que vale la pena aclarar
cuando tú haces la clasificación de los
diferentes documentos quien tiene la
potestad de desclasificar documentos en
los Estados Unidos es el presidente el
presidente Trump con el hecho mismo de
sacar los documentos de la Casa Blanca
está usando su poder para desclasificar
esos documentos y esos documentos
automáticamente serían desclasificados
no tiene esa potestad del vicepresidente
de los Estados Unidos el señor biden
cuando sacó esos documentos de la Casa
Blanca era vicepresidente y no tenía la
potestad para desclasificarlos de manera
que pues en la práctica el tener los
documentos en su casa significa que el
presidente Trump los desclasificó algo
para lo cual estaba pues debidamente
apoderado tenía la la condición de
hacerlo tenía la facultad de hacer de
manera que pues nada de eso ha sido
tenido en cuenta Seguramente se tendrá
en cuenta dentro del proceso y nosotros
no descartamos la posibilidad de que
cuando esto termine termine como otra
cortina de humo que se ha creado con el
ánimo de perjudicar las posibilidades
electorales del presidente Trump iba a
ser otra vez otro fracaso como lo fueron
los impitchments de Nancy pelosi y las
otras acciones que los demócratas han
emprendido eso sucede con alguna
frecuencia cuando una colectividad no
tiene un líder no le queda más remedio
que destruir el líder de la otra
colectividad Antonio tenía potestad
legal Donald Trump de desclasificar los
documentos que se llevó de la Casa
Blanca el 20 de enero de 2021 una vez
dejó la presidencia
tengamos en cuenta y creo que lo
importante acá es el nivel de la
clasificación cuando son cosas que son
top Secret son cosas que ponen al país
en un riesgo Okay a alto de que algo
puede suceder documentos como tales como
yo siendo veterano que sirvió en el
ejército de los Estados Unidos Sabiendo
la diferencia entre las clasificaciones
sabemos que un documento no ha
arbitrariamente lo lo van a
desclasificar porque al desclasificar
algo quiere decir que todo el país puede
tener acceso a ese documento lo cual
quiere decir que secretos de nuestra
nación secretos sobre a maneras del
ejército de operar de nuestros
a países con los con los que colaboramos
a podrían estar en riesgo si como el
señor Jaime declara simplemente él en su
mente dice sabes que lo voy a de
clasificar porque me dé la gana
funcionan así Si fuera así no tuviéramos
el tipo de de seguridad e inteligencia
que existen los Estados Unidos porque
Tratamos de guardar esa información
clasificada secreta y especialmente
para proteger nuestros intereses y
nuestra seguridad nacional Así que no es
no es así como de que él subjetivamente
diga y él mismo en el diaiment se da a
ver que en parte de los comentarios en
el donde él está hablando con un
reportero donde le estaba presentando
información secreta
ocre donde él mismo había dicho yo podía
haber
desclasificado esto pero no lo hice Ah y
y sabemos que que no es solo
de desclasificar algo porque al final
del día tenemos que entender que es la
seguridad Nacional de los Estados Unidos
que está en juego cuando esas acciones
se toman y al tomarlas esos se
convierten públicos para que cualquier
persona
del público lo pueda adquirir usted
precisamente menciona la acusación y la
información que habría compartido Donald
Trump de hecho en esta acusación señalan
al expresidente de compartir en dos
ocasiones documentos o la información de
los documentos clasificados en 2021 una
con como usted lo dice un escritor un
editor y dos miembros de su personal
describiendo un presunto ataque contra
el mismo Trump y otro que le mostró a un
representante desde su comité de acción
política un mapa también clasificado y
la acusación dice que Trump tenía estos
documentos en lugares nada seguros en
mara lago Jaime Cuál es su opinión
respecto al nivel de seguridad o no que
tenían estos documentos clasificados
a ver María Clara es interesante porque
pues estas consideraciones sobre la
seguridad y los riesgos que significan
los documentos parece que aplican
solamente para los que tenía Trump no
aplican para los que tenía biden en un
garaje en un garaje en su casa desde la
ure donde entraba y salía cualquier
persona donde además estuvo el
presentador de televisión David
lettermann haciendo un programa sobre
carros pues cubriendo la información
sobre el Corvette favorito del
presidente biden parece que las
consideraciones sobre seguridad solo
aplican para los documentos que tenía
biden pero no para los documentos que
tenía Perdón para los documentos que
tenía Trump pero no para los que tenía
biden entre otras cosas algunos de ellos
En el centro de pensamiento de la
Universidad de Pensilvania que fue
construido con dineros del partido
comunista chino de manera que pues ahí
si hay riesgos de seguridad Nacional de
Gran envergadura y sobre eso no tenemos
conocimiento de nada las autoridades no
han hecho la menor investigación o por
lo menos no han divulgado nada acerca de
esto mientras que en el caso de Trump ya
van en un proceso ya le levantaron siete
cargos en fin todo ese tipo de cosas
explíquenme cómo la justicia funciona
esa velocidad y con esa eficiencia
cuando se trata del expresidente de
republicano y no cuando se trata del ex
vicepresidente demócrata por favor
Antonio qué responderle a esa pregunta
que nos plantea Jaime de Por qué la
justicia va tan rápido en el caso de
Trump y en el caso de biden como bien lo
dice no hay detalles no se conoce ni
siquiera la cantidad de documentos
clasificados que encontraron o no no Y
si hay o no documentos clasificados y
como bien lo dijo Jaime y lo señaló
Donald Trump en uno de sus discursos
haciendo este vínculo entre el partido
comunista chino y la universidad de
Pensilvania
Bueno
al partido republicano le encanta usar
la la palabra comunista en cualquier
oportunidad que tienen sabemos que como
les decía anteriormente no sabemos A qué
nivel está la investigación
del de los récords que tenía de cuando
era vicepresidente a como también no
sabemos cómo va la investigación a con
Mike pence que de igual manera tenía
documentos a tampoco no sabemos aunque
sea hasta el momento sí no sé a qué
punto van a a a divulgar verdad si a los
documentos que se tenían y el nivel de
clasificación de esos documentos Pero
sabemos que esto tampoco no empezó ayer
la librería
desde que él salió de su puesto como
presidente ha estado pidiendo esos
documentos Okay y y durante todo el
tiempo
el expresidente Trump siguió ignorando
se tuvo que involucrar a el departamento
de Justicia para tratar de recuperar
esos materiales que Vuelvo y repito le
pertenecen al gobierno de los Estados
Unidos y no al presidente Trump como de
igual manera no le pertenece a cualquier
persona que sale de su posición estando
yéndose siendo un veterano Por ejemplo
yo si hubiera llevado un material
secreto tabciker o hasta clases fuera de
mi base podría presentarse cargos no
solo militares pero también a federales
a a por esas tipos de acciones tenemos a
diferentes procesos y leyes en en en
puesto para proteger esa clase de
información Ahora sí abriera ya dado a
luz que en las búsquedas del
vicepresidente pence o del
vicepresidente vayan cuando él era
vicepresidente se encontraban materiales
de nivel clasificados
Secret la conversación fuera diferente
que estuviéramos tomando ahorita si no
se ha tomado ninguna acción contra las
personas de ellos dos Ah pero no estamos
en esa posición ahorita sabemos que ya
llegó a un punto la investigación con
down donde han encontrado a lo que
estamos hablando hoy como usted bien lo
señala la administración Nacional de
archivos y registros le pidió desde el 6
de mayo de 2021 al expresidente Donald
Trump que devolviera estos documentos es
decir cuatro meses después de que dejó
la presidencia sin embargo quiero
insistirle en una pregunta usted reitera
no se sabe en qué está la investigación
contra Joe biden no se saben que estaba
la investigación contra Mike pence el ex
vicepresidente de Donald Trump a quien
también le allanaron documentos Pero por
qué cree usted que en esos dos casos no
se conocen los detalles como si se
conocen en el caso de Trump
bueno primero que todo ya se ya se soltó
el envimen sobre el caso de de Trump y
tuvieron que
sacar una orden de de búsqueda verdad
uno un software para poder entrar a la
propiedad sacar más información porque
él no quería de su parte a darle
información o estaba a falsamente
declarando que ya no tenía nada cuando
ahora sabemos que no era así Ah el
proceso de él ya fue por un rangery
donde granja vio la información que se
presentó y declaró que puede presentar
los cargos Vuelvo y repito eso no quiere
decir que él ha sido encontrado culpable
de los 37 cargos que enfrenta a sino que
a solo ha sido cargado eventuals con es
con esas acciones eso todavía tiene que
proceder en las Cortes sabemos que la
jueza en Florida que lleva el caso es
una persona que el presidente Don
puso en su posición como jueza sabemos
que en el pasado a la corte de apelación
ha tuvo que reversar a la orden original
del Word Ah porque ella siendo apuesta
en su posición por Donald Trump había
encontrado de manera diferente y la
corte de apelación a que también tenía a
personas nombradas por Trump reversó esa
acción Jaime quiero cambiar un poco de
tema y enfocarnos en la estrategia de
Donald Trump tanto en su discurso de
Georgia como en el discurso que dio en
Nueva Jersey vemos un poco que él se
está concentrando en atacar a Joe biden
no solo tildándolo como el presidente
más corrupto de la historia del país
sino también comparando su caso con el
caso de los documentos encontrados en la
casa de Delaware y también en la
universidad de Pensilvania e incluso
mencionó a bill Clinton un caso que es
muy distinto al de él porque lo que
encontraron en Bill Clinton fue una
cinta de grabación con una entrevista de
un historiador que estaba haciendo un
poco como la vida y obra débil Clinton
Usted cree que Trump podría continuar
esta estrategia y que tanto le podría
servir o no dado que esto no defiende
necesariamente su inocencia
a ver María Clara eso hace parte de la
estrategia que él ha marcado con sus
abogados Seguramente se han puesto de
acuerdo en esto a mí me queda un poco
complicado entrar en estos temas porque
como funcionario del comité nacional
republicano estoy obligado a mantener
neutralidad en el tema de las elecciones
primarias hasta que no se define A quién
va a ser el candidato y siendo Donald
Trump uno de los precandidatos Pues
nosotros tenemos que mantenernos
aislados a esto yo quiero aprovechar
esta oportunidad solo para traer a
colación un tema porque ellos mencionan
con mucha frecuencia que el presidente
Se demoró mucho tiempo en responder la
solicitudes del archivo nacional
dicen que la solicitud inicial del
archivo nacional se produce el seis de
mayo del año 2021 recordemos que Para
marzo del 2021 el país comenzó a
paralizarse como resultado la pandemia
del covid 19 a mí personalmente me
consta que el archivo nacional estuvo
cerrado por más de un año sus
funcionarios operaban desde sus casas y
no tenían acceso a los archivos de
manera que no había no estaba
funcionando casi por dos años el archivo
Nacional de manera que ese tiempo que
transcurrió entre el año 2001 y el año
2023 en el que estamos es mucho menos
tiempo del que los demócratas dicen que
el presidente Trump Se demoró para
devolver los documentos el estilo del
presidente es ese y sus abogados
seguramente le habrán dado Cuál es la
estrategia que debe seguir nosotros como
republicanos estamos muy inconformes con
los hechos de corrupción que hemos
venido pues evidenciando desde hace
tiempo y que la cámara de representantes
está analizando y sí efectivamente Pues
debería haber unas investigaciones mucho
más profundas para empezar con el
computador de Hunter biden que la prensa
y las mismas autoridades se encargaron
de desmentir diciendo que se trataba de
intervención rusa en la política interna
de los Estados Unidos y terminaron Pues
demostrandoles que era justamente lo
contrario y nadie ha salido a
disculparse por el asunto ni siquiera
los mismos periódicos que salieron a
desmentir al New York post que fue el
que trajo la información original del
computador del hijo del vicepresidente
aquí quiero otra preguntarle algo usted
menciona que el país estaba paralizado
por la pandemia y que esto produjo que
la administración de archivos estuviera
cerrada y esto impidió que Donald Trump
entregara todos los documentos sin
embargo Mi pregunta es por qué en enero
de 2022 cuando Donald Trump entregó 15
cajas de documentos no los entregó todos
al punto que en agosto cuando ya el FBI
fue a allanar Mara lago encontró más
documentos
a ver María Clara ustedes vieron ustedes
mismos mostraron las imágenes las
acabamos de rever en esta misma en este
mismo reportaje que nos estás haciendo
en ese mismo programa vimos las imágenes
de las cajas arrumadas una encima de la
otra a ver si el expresidente de los
Estados Unidos con todas las ocupaciones
que tiene tiene tiempo para sentarse a
abrir caja por caja y revisar documento
por documento para ver cuáles son de
unos o cuáles son de otros realmente es
algo muy difícil de hacer entregaron las
cajas además cuando se produce una
mudanza de la salida de un presidente de
la casa blanco o de cualquier Palacio
presidencial en cualquier parte del
mundo no es el presidente saliente el
que está revisando cada caja y cada
documento que hay en cada una de las
cajas de manera que pues esto es un poco
más difícil de lo que parece y Quieren
poner como el culpable de todo esto al
presidente cuando todos sabemos que es
físicamente imposible que el presidente
tenga conocimiento de cada uno de los
documentos que hay en cientos de cajas
que están armadas en su en su en su casa
de Mara lago completamente distinto de
lo que sucede con el ex vicepresidente
que además han transcurrido más de ocho
años desde que esos documentos salieron
de la casa blanca y han estado a Merced
vaya uno a saber de quién tanto en la
universidad de Pensilvania como en el
garaje de su casa en Delaware quiero
hacerle otra pregunta de otro tema
Antonio como viene lo decía Jaime
anteriormente los republicanos siguen
respaldando a Donald Trump Incluso en
medio de esta acusación penal y de hecho
routers epsos publicaron una encuesta en
la que decía que el 81% de los
republicanos consideran que esto es una
cacería de brujas e incluso el mismo ex
vicepresidente Mike pence quien también
es precandidato republicano afirmó que
todas estos casos contra Trump lo único
que hacían era fortalecerlo ante sus
votantes usted considera que este caso
le da más fuerza política a Donald Trump
como candidato
eso está por verse en parte de los
votantes y en la primaria del presidente
Trump para clarificar algo acuérdense
que cuando estuve estuvimos cerrados por
covid fue en el 2020 ok No fue en el
2021 como estamos tratando de de de de
de anunciar que fue mayo del 2021 no
las elecciones fueron en el 2020
pero el las oficinas gubernamentales
estaban cerrando en el 2020 no en el
2021 ya parale el tiempo que tomó
posición el presidente ya las oficinas
por la gran mayoría ya habían regresado
a a estar abiertas ahora aparte en base
a a lo que vaya a hacer o no el partido
republicano a en las primarias que
vienen a es de darse por ver verdad
Ellos tienen esa decisión de poder
elegir una persona que ellos piensan que
va a ser el mejor candidato para
representar el partido sabemos también
que a diferencia de de lo que se ha
dicho OK Yo soy un abogado por carrera y
cuando hay un sepina o hay una
información que viene del Gobierno
Federal y uno tiene abogados presentes
los abogados buscan por cada y una cosa
a que se nos presenta porque ese es
nuestro labor de defender nuestro
cliente de la mejor manera posible y es
posible a poder buscar por todas estas
cajas Especialmente cuando los
documentos que estamos hablando están
marcadas Obviamente que son secretos o
tabs Secret o clasificado no es algo
donde es una línea pequeñita que no se
lee es algo bien grande y claro y visual
cuando estamos hablando de los
documentos que se estaban hablando
Antonio lo voy a interrumpir lo voy a
interrumpir porque se nos está acabando
el tiempo y quiero darle la oportunidad
a Jaime de que nos diga si esto podría
fortalecer o no la precandidatura de
Donald Trump muy brevemente
sin duda no solamente pues las encuestas
así lo están demostrando sino además la
recaudación de fondos de campaña está
dejando muy claro que pues al contrario
de lo que los demócratas quieren con
todos estos ataques debidamente
concertados
el presidente se está fortaleciendo y
Jaime su conclusión de cómo entender
este caso en 30 segundos
a ver nosotros creemos que hay dos
medidas dos raseros para imponer la
justicia en los Estados Unidos creemos
que cuando el acusado es republicano se
le trata de una forma cuando el acusado
es demócrata y particularmente cuando
está vinculado con la administración
actual se le trata de otra Nosotros sí
creemos que hay una cacería de brujas
que el interés es justamente eh
perjudicar la imagen del presidente
Trump en su aspiración para ser el
nominado presidencial republicano en la
convención del próximo año Antonio
Molina a su conclusión es 30 segundos
bueno todo esto está enfrente de el
sistema judicial a eso se va a dar a ver
verdad sabemos que no es el único caso
presente que que tiene que que combatir
a el expresidente
todo eso se va a ver en las Cortes a
Cuáles son los resultados es el
departamento de Justicia que tiene labor
a nivel Federal de proceder con estas
investigaciones Ah Y eso se va a dar a
luz
Jaime flores y Antonio Molina Gracias
por acompañarnos aquí en el debate de
France 24 de la producción de este
programa estuvo a cargo de Andrés
doncell y la de los invitados con Tania
Herrera ustedes sigan conectados a flash
[Música]